jordan pas bonjour mademoiselle joola
qu'est ce qui t'arrive kazimi je
désirerais tu as tout y est poivre lui
doit j'ai fait que quasi bien expliquer
d'abord pourquoi tu es dans cette tenue
et qu'est-ce qui se passe non non non
pas avant que vous mettiez donner ma
tâche de quais khaimah poivre du doigt
gx bon alors ta tasse de thé ben la
voilà voilà ta tasse de thé les dragées
au point va je n'en ai pas et et les
bonbons fourrés non plus ça c'est par
exemple alors si c'est bien je suis
désordonnée comme dit françois mais je
suis sûr que j'avais ces deux beaucoup
ici peut-être toi je vous ai dit allez
on va trouver des coûts de casimir cesse
d'imiter monsieur mère de famille et dix
mois plus tôt pourquoi dieu dans cette
mort tu n'es pas drôle je dis bon je
t'explique là j'ai rencontré françois ce
matin au port et je n'y ai dit que je
souhaiterais rencontré monsieur fall
metz j'aimerais faire son métier alors
qu'il m'a dit qu'ils viendraient ici cet
après midi mehdi prend déjà pour un
détective
je suis belle et magnifique je lui
demande moi de chercher son côté a perdu
le coup tu que gémir tu n'es pas encore
détective laisse moi me concentrais deux
minutes pour faire l'ordre dans mes
idées savoie où sont ces beaucoup mon
bonjour mademoiselle
eh bien vous tombez bien monsieur
merlotte famille figurez vous que j'ai
deux beaucoup de bonbons qui ont disparu
tiens beaucoup formez vous là une chose
merveilleuse connaître le premier le
sien de ce quinze minutes un petit doigt
me dit que vous aimeriez être détective
n'est ce pas comment me trouvez vous
monsieur pharma ont pas mal pas mal du
tout mais c'est que j'ai mieux mais ce
ne sont ni lundi ni la loupe qui font le
détective ne nous avons tout esprit de
déduction qu'est ce que c'est que ça les
deux du corps comme on dit boucle la
déduction oif et bien sûr que c'est
mieux dans ce cas précis n'est ce pas
c'est un raisonnement qui avec l'aide de
petits faits précis que l'on découvre
les indices nous permettre de découvrir
ce qui se produit le comprennent et
année vous allez
nous avons un problème qui nous est
posée par mademoiselle chez lui ici
présentés ensemble together ils ont
essayé de le résoudre donc la nouvelle
julie avant vos bocaux bambins ont
disparu
apparemment ce ne sont pas nos jade non
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
hm
smartphones mais je suis heureux de vous
trouver excuse est né le 6 décembre
mais ce n'est pas veut qu'ils trouvaient
ces jeux je vous écoute quinzaine voilà
makane kane mes ancêtres a disparu je
l'avais posée hier à mon vestibule ce
matin je me lève je m'apprête à sortir
j'ai pour la prendre elle n'est plus là
voulaient une sécurité
une seconde énigme j'en déduis que vous
avez rencontré mademoiselle chuter alors
ok ah non non ce matin seulement
mademoiselle julie j'ai vu et s'il peut
tout bon goût ont disparu dans la nature
alors il n'y a pas deux mais trois
énigmes 1,3 unis comme je suis gâté
quelle je suis gâté l'expliquez vous
mais voilà en venant le certains gérants
contre moi a ajouté qu'ils étaient
affolés car ces terres biais avait
disparu
il faut croyez monsieur merlan femme que
ces disparitions ont un rapport entre
elles
je ne sais pas c'est encore une belle
julie
kazemi a été fait dans cette tenue je
suis moi-même dit-il comme sur fall mais
ça et si vous avez besoin de retrouver
quelque chose
contacté le détecte états unis avait dit
de nous dire vous ne semblez bien bien
sûr de vous me gênait les mots mais je
n'en suis pas votre jeune élève mon
vieil ami jeu suivant pro concurrents et
je vais vous trouvez genre gold rendez
vous ici mènent dans un quart d'heure et
je vous assure que j'aurai retrouvé tous
les objets perdus ah ah on verra
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai trouvé la solution
mais celle-ci est gêné je venais venez
vite avec moi par contre ici nous allons
prendre femme qui raccourcit d'accord
[Musique]
[Rires]
et bien voilà nous sommes arrivés juste
à temps mais maintenant il s'agit
d'ouvrir l'oeil et le bon gentil fils
attendait pectives à je suis un grand
détective voilà j'ai retrouvé la can de
monsieur l'histoire et les bonbons de
julie
là et les herbiers de mademoiselle foot
est
maintenant il ne me reste plus qu'à
reporter tout ça dans le jardin et leur
montrer qui est le plus grand détective
mais personne ne veut croire elle cite
les aimer c'est toi qui as mais bon bout
et makan et les un billet de maine -
futures wall et alors et alors vous
n'êtes pas digne de tintin détective
puisque c'est vous qui avaient tous
utilisés bon vous avez raison monsieur
fort mais je ne suis pas un grand
détective mais c'est surtout parce qu'il
ya une chose que je n'ai pas réussi à
prendre à vridi passionnant qu'est ce
que c'est monsieur qu'est venu gros
krach sans ridicule à
kasubi
on annonce
kesy b
[Musique]